all right Sean we are going to skip the
intro this week we're going to do
something a little bit different so this
will be the section where you sort of
paste in the beautiful theme song that
we
[Music]
have every little thing you think that
you need every little thing you think
that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greet oh I bet that you be
fine without
it hello everyone welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less I'm Joshua Fields Milburn and we're
doing this a bit different today I'm by
myself Ryan is on vacation sort of his
family's in town uh he has like eight
people staying in his tiny little
apartment which is hilarious uh he and
and like his entire side of his mother's
family and we are doing this live on
Periscope right now as well as we'll
post this up on on the podcast later
hopefully if it goes well if not you
will never hear this other than on
Periscope so welcome y'all now I won't
be looking at a lot of the questions
here on Periscope but because I already
have a ton of questions for people and I
this is a little bit different because
I'm not doing any prep work for this one
usually Ryan and I prepare for I don't
know four to six hours for a podcast
we'll prepare the day before and then
the morning of the podcast and and not
prepare our answers but we'll do some
research we will we'll do some talking
and we we'll do some different things to
try to make sure that we're ready to
record on a particular subject as most
of you have probably noticed many of our
podcast episodes will center around a
particular theme or Motif so whether
it's decluttering or sentimental items
or relationships or whatever this one's
a bit different this is just going to be
a solo episode with me and I'm going to
answer a bunch of random questions that
were selected very randomly here both
voicemails and from uh social media
before we get started though a little
bit of housekeeping Ryan and I are
taking this podcast on the road in May
and I am so excited about that I know
Ryan is too we're going to be in more
than a dozen cities we'll be in New York
City on May 1st 2016 and from there
we're going to be in Boston and
Washington DC
and Miami and Dallas and Dayton Ohio
back at in our hometown for a day and
then we'll be in Chicago Seattle San
Francisco Los Angeles Salt Lake City
Missoula Montana and our our current
Hometown and then we're going to finish
the tour in Canada and Toronto Canada
actually and so we're going to be doing
that all throughout May May 1st to June
1st we're bringing our documentary with
us as well it's called minimalism a
documentary about the important things
and you can join join us uh for that
we're going to screen the documentary
we're going to do a live Q&A session uh
we're going to record it for the podcast
and uh we'll of course do our favorite
part which is dishing out tens of
thousands of hugs throughout uh
throughout the the the tour a after all
of our Q&A and everything so we have a
bunch of people on on Periscope and
Twitter who are watching us right now or
I should say watching me right now
there's a microphone in front of my face
so um it's probably a better view than
if it was just me staring at a camera so
um I'm going to get move on to our first
voicemail question and this one is from
Katherine I am one of the few people who
is lucky enough to work in the industry
that I also am passionate about however
the problem is is that when I get home
from my Daily Grind at the office from 8
to 5 to come home and my passion project
is the same thing that I've just spent
the last 10 hours working on I have a
hard time being motivated to to work on
my passion project because it utilizes
the same skill set do you guys have any
advice so any advice about your passion
project really I think the question
maybe if I were to rephrase the question
a bit is can you get burned out on your
passion and the answer is absolutely yes
you you you certainly can and that means
you don't have enough balance at times
and I think we we all struggle with this
especially uh me because if I get really
passionate about something that comes
after all of the so maybe I've been
excited about a a topic or or something
for a while but I've drudged through the
drudgery and now I'm starting to get
this payoff and it feels very meaningful
it's a purpose-driven work and and I
think that's awesome but we also have to
take time to balance out our life and
our first book and so Kath and I'm going
to send you a copy of our first book uh
which is uh minimalism live a meaningful
life and in that book we talk about the
five values of uh living a a more
deliberate more intentional life and
only one of those is is Passion but
there are four other values as well and
and the problem is if we get too focused
on one thing one one bucket of those
five buckets one area we just we call
them values if we get too focused on one
value in life what happens is we forsake
the other values and we're only as
strong as our our our weakest value and
so just going through those five values
real quick Health
relationships passion growth
contribution so you see you can have
four of those buckets where you're
really focused on them let's say You're
really focused on your passion project
everything's going awesome and and you
you're knocking it out of the park you
feel like all of your work is so
purposeful that you have a sense of
auton autonomy you are mastering what
you're doing and you're making good
money you whatever that's great but
let's say you're also you're really
focused on your relationships and your
marriage is going well and all of a
sudden you know you feel like your
friends that you've surrounded yourself
with share your similar values they
share similar interests that's great
let's say you feel like you're growing
because of your relationships and also
your your uh uh passion and and you're
doing new things in life you you're
making yourself uncomfortable so you're
able to grow you're also contributing to
your community which makes you feel
wonderful because of course giving is
living but let's say you don't have that
first value in place let's say your
health is really struggling and you're
eating fast food every day cuz that's
easier you're not taking the time to
work out you're not taking the time to
connect with your body well yeah you're
going you're going to feel like
something is missing and you're going to
burn yourself out and so it's really
about achieving balance and mastering
all five areas and it may mean it
doesn't mean focusing on all five at the
same exact moment but every day I will
try to do something that is really
focused on one of those areas and then
focus on all of them throughout the day
and the best way I found to do that is
ask myself with whatever I'm doing
whether it's you know browsing Facebook
or spending time with with close friends
or recording a podcast I I ask myself
and what values does this serve and if
you ask that question enough you you'll
learn that it becomes habitual and if
you're serving more than one value
that's even better right because as I'm
recording this podcast I'm certainly
growing we we have a we we have a innate
desire to grow and I am uncomfortable
recording a podcast especially doing it
live like we're doing right now on
Periscope and and Twitter and so I am
not necessarily comfortable doing this
but because I have put myself in a
position of discomfort that is a
position from which I grow the most I
also feel like I I'm able to contribute
because I'm able to share my sort of uh
knowledge that I've gained over time
with regards to minimalism or life
experience I'm able to share that with
other people so I'm able to contribute
to the world around me in a meaningful
way so I'm fulfilling a couple different
values there as well as soon as I finish
this uh recording this podcast I'm going
to go for a long walk cuz it's finally
sunny here and beautiful Missoula
Montana which is where I'm at right now
and and so I'm going to go for a walk
which AIDS my health you know I can also
do some something meditative while I'm
walking uh which is a different type of
Health you mental health you might say
or removing mental clutter I might also
listen to a podcast or some music find a
way to to grow in that way learn
something new
our next question is from
Rachel I am going to be starting up uh
College next year so I would kind of I
would kind of like to hear your
perspective on that um it's going to be
a big transition period um I would i'
kind of like to hear what would be a
good way to stay minimalist during
college um while keeping track of
assignments keeping track of you know
old papers and textbooks and um you know
the busy lifestyle that um you kind of
have to face during college so you know
what what would be a good way to be able
to
stay um keep keep living a minimal
lifestyle um during that Rael the first
thing you're going to have to do is
realize there are going to be tools that
are going to augment your experience
whether it's college or moving into the
workforce or going on a camping trip or
going skiing there are tools that can
actually help our experience be better
and so minimalism is not about
deprivation minimalism is about finding
the right tools the appropriate tools
for the task at hand Ryan often talks
about how he is he's a snowboarder right
he loves snowboarding goes snowboarding
all the time and so in order to do that
it'd be pretty difficult to do without
the appropriate equipment he needs a
snowboard he need he needs the sort of
auta that goes with with snowboarding
now if I had those same trinkets that's
all they would be to me or trinkets I
would have a a snowboard in a closet
somewhere I'm not going to use it I
don't go snowboarding personally I've
tried and I I don't enjoy it and I've
actually injured myself doing that and
so you know for me it it's really about
figuring out what tools are appropriate
now once you've determined that it
doesn't mean that you're going to be
right 100% of the time sometimes you're
going to bring tools in you realize I
don't actually need this and then it's
about finding it a new home finding
someone else who can get value from that
thing also with respect to minimalism
and applying minimalism to the college
life or any other lifestyle I find that
the best way to do it is to bring as few
things in as possible especially once
we've cleared the Clutter from our lives
the the average American household has
more than 300,000 items in it and and
it's up to us to to clear the excess out
of the way but once we've cleared the
excess it's just as important if not
more important to stop the excess from
being excess before it even comes into
our lives that's the easiest way to deal
with it because you're not going to have
to declutter those hundred things if
you've brought in only 10 of the H
hundred that you might might have
brought in so you bring in things
deliberately into your life there are a
few ways to do that is start to ask some
questions does this thing add value to
my life is this appropriate for my life
is this a tool is it going to serve a
purpose is it going to bring me joy and
the cool thing about that is it Chang es
over time and so minimalists aren't
against consumption we're against
compulsory consumption so we are going
to bring things into our lives and as
our circumstances change our our our
tools will change as well I was uh I was
shopping this weekend with uh with Becca
we were getting a new high chair for um
for Ella we were actually out in in um
Seattle this weekend and while we were
there we we stopped at Ikea which if
anyone knows me or has read everything
that remains which is the Memoir that
Ryan and I wrote there's a whole sort of
dissertation about Ikea in fact that
dissertation made it into our
documentary uh so Riel actually you're
in Tucson uh good news for you we have a
screening of our documentary uh in
coming up in Tucson and I'd love to send
you a couple tickets to that documentary
so you can you can see my disdain for
the impulsive purchase of uh of items
but someone recognized me Sean when I
was at at Ikea this weekend and uh it
makes me easier if I have someone to
talk to so I'm just talking to Sean here
um he's our our our trustful trustworthy
and and and astute producer of of the
podcast anyway I was at Ikea this
weekend buying a new high chair for for
Ella and um someone recognized me and he
he pulled me up on the phone is is this
you and I'm like yeah it's me and I'm
like I swear I'm I'm shopping for a
friend you know because but here here's
the truth like we we go there's nothing
inherently wrong with Ikea or anything
else uh the problem and I I wrote about
this and and everything that remains is
the time that I first discovered
minimalism was in a very difficult uh
time in my life uh my mom had died and
my marriage ended both in the same month
and oh I I instead of dealing with those
things headon which is the appropriate
way to deal with it I found myself
trying to mask and cover up the problem
with with buying trinkets and buying
what I'm supposed to buy cuz my marriage
ended so I moved into a new apartment
and and the line from the book is while
Rome is burning there's somehow time for
shopping at Ikea and and I found myself
like buying all these things that you're
supposed to buy and there's nothing
wrong with the stuff the the question
was I wasn't questioning what I was
bringing in my life oh I'm supposed to
have this uh throw pillow I'm supposed
to have this couch and a love seat and a
chair and a desk and a a desk chair and
a and a a lamp and another lamp for over
there and and all of these things you're
supposed to have and there's nothing
wrong with a lot of those things I have
you know plenty of things I have a bath
rug it's okay to have that the question
is am I actually questioning bringing
this into my life or am I just bring it
into my life because that's what I'm
supposed to do so ryel I would encourage
you to ask those questions as you're
bringing those things in is this
actually going to be useful is this
going to serve a purpose what I'm going
to do is this going to make my
experience better and don't just justify
it you know what you have to be honest
with yourself and and maybe the way to
be honest with yourself if you're not
sure is to just say I don't know let me
go without it for a little bit temporary
deprivation to see whether or not I'm
actually going to need this so give
yourself a time period a week two weeks
a month whatever it may be and I do that
with most big purchases anything over a
100 bucks I I tend to wait 30 days
before I'm going to to purchase it I
know other people it's 20 bucks if I'm
not not going to spend more than $20 on
this thing if uh if I haven't at least
ruminated on it for for a month so ryel
we're going to send you a couple tickets
to the Tucson screening of uh minimalism
a documentary about the important things
and for anyone else who's who's
listening wants to find the the theater
closest to them because we're showing in
uh 400 Theaters starting May 24th 2016
you can just go to minimalism film.com
and click on see the film and you can
find a theater closest to you here's the
deal with that it is showing usually in
most cities for one night only uh
sometimes it may do more than one night
but honestly and most realistically if
it doesn't get enough showings in in one
one night it's not going to show for
weeks and weeks now if you help it tip
meaning we have enough people who who go
see this the film then it will show for
a longer duration and for those of you
overseas don't worry uh we are still
working on overseas distribution we're
starting with Canada and Australia and
we're going to see where else we can go
from there and eventually we'll do an
online Online release of the film as
well our next question is from
Heather my husband and I have actually
recently started our minimalist journey
and we're doing great so far um but my
sister-in-law is getting married in a
few months and she is kind of expecting
my husband and I to go into debt for her
wedding we are not quite sure how to
tell her that we are not going to be
doing that um because we just can't
afford to do it at this time and as you
guys say no debt is good debt so no debt
is good debt that that's an interesting
way that's that's a interesting play on
words but our usual phrase is right I
will say there is no such thing as good
debt no debt is good debt I love that
that's like I need to write that down
for a blog post title uh later uh no I I
I do believe that that there's no such
thing as good debt now there are times
where going to the debt may be necessary
for a a family member's wedding that's
certainly not one of them uh the time
that I can see where debt is most
necessary is often when someone wants to
get a mortgage then I often recommend if
you can't pay cash for a house which I I
can't right now and that's why I rent
personally but I do recommend you a
seven-year fixed rate mortgage and
having 20 to 50% down if that is a a
good choice for you and your family and
you know you're going to be in City for
at least 7 years that's when it tends to
make sense mathematically now in terms
of other debt yes there are some debts
that are better than others student loan
may be better than a a payday loan
actually not maybe it certainly is
although many student loans I mean if if
you know we have something like 60% of
people who actually finish college Who
start then you know many people myself
included I had six figures worth of debt
some of that would student loans now I
don't have a college degree but I had
heaps of student loans now I'll let you
figure that out but was that a good use
of my money certainly not I was paying
off uh something that I I I didn't
actually have value in and it's
interesting we do that with a lot of
things a lot of a lot of people myself
included have just endless numbers of
credit cards or I had endless numbers of
credit cards I had 14 credit cards so
I'd have the Banana Republic credit card
or I would have the Best Buy credit card
because you go somewhere and they're
like would you like to save 15% on this
t-shirt you're like yeah just fill out
this piece of paper and you and it's
crazy but but that's what we do uh debt
is is not good because it traps us it
anchors us to obligations obligations
being an income being a job being a
location it it anchors Us in not a good
way when you think of anchors we often
hear that oh my goodness you are such an
anchored person like it's a compliment
but when you think about that you flip
it on its head anchored really means
what it means that we are
stuck if you think of a ship that is
anchored it is you've put an anchor down
it's at Bay it's keeping it from roaming
the Seas and being free and so debt is
the obverse side of freedom and I found
that by getting rid of debt I I didn't I
was almost 32 years old by the time I I
finally got out of debt so it was even
after I I walked away from the corporate
world but I had to put a very uh
specific plan together for those of you
who are interested in reading that plan
you can find it at theminimalists.com
Freedom it's a it's a very long very
difficult plan uh actually but it's
easy it's not I'm sorry it's not easy
it's simple simple is not easy and and
and that that's the thing that I try to
drive home with people it's a fairly
simple plan I'll just go through a few
things for the people are listen and
then I promise I will answer your
question about going into debt for um
what you're trying to to to do in terms
of this sweating but uh the essay itself
that that Ryan and I wrote and uh it's
called Financial Freedom five difficult
steps to get out of debt create a simple
budget plan for the future and regain
control of your finances these are all
things that are important now now there
are two words that that are in the title
of that five difficult steps because I
don't want to pretend that it's easy
it's not easy to get out of debt but
nothing that's really worth doing is is
is easy now that doesn't mean that it's
not simple simple means that is
deliberate easy means it's the path of
least resistance and so we want to be
careful when we we confuse those two
terms and often they are used
synonymously but to me they're they're
opposites from each other they're
antonyms because they they mean two
different things uh it going with the
flow I'm looking at a river out out my
window right now in the summer people
are floating down this River at all the
time they're going with the flow now
that is easy right now it's interesting
because if they were to keep going with
the flow here there are some Rapids that
show up in about two miles from here and
that's the problem with with continuing
to go with the flow all the time
eventually you show up at the Rapids or
show up at the Falls and if you don't
have a plan because you've just been
going with the flow the whole time well
then you are in for a world of hurt now
simple is putting on your wet suit
grabbing your wake board and and going
down to those Rapids which I guarantee
that because it's sunny out there people
are doing that right now and and it's
fairly simple but but it is it is not
easy it's a difficult task and and
people are in the same body of water
some people are taking it easy and some
people are taking it simple and enjoying
that time and finding a meaningful
experience in doing it so in terms of
going into debt how do you communicate
that you're not willing to go into debt
uh first off you need to sit down with
you and your husband and and have that
conversation together and and and
eventually uh you you need to to bring
your family into the fold and say you
know look we are not willing to go into
debt um in order to to pay for your
wedding and or or to take the trip I'm
not really sure what the circumstances
are surrounding that but but ultimately
it's not something that's in our budget
right now and and the way to approach
that is say I can't afford this as
opposed to saying I don't want to go
into debt for this and and I think it's
distinctly different before I purchase
something uh two questions that I ask is
is this going to add value to my life
and that's great if it will uh but the
second question is equally as important
is can I afford this and what you're
saying right now is you can't afford it
it's not about not going into debt you
don't have the capital or you're not
willing to spend the capital maybe you
have $100,000 in the bank and this
wedding is going to cost you 20,000 and
you're saying well I'm not willing to
take $20,000 out and maybe that's the
better question ask yourself right now
is if I had 100 Grand in the bank would
would I still be willing to spend this 5
10 20 grand and if so great that means
yes it would add value to your life the
second question is can I afford this and
if you can't afford it it's okay to say
that you can't afford something I just
told you a minute ago I can't afford to
buy a house right now there's wrong with
that I don't feel ashamed to not be able
to buy a house I don't have the cash in
the bank to do that now could I finance
a house of course I have good credit but
I don't need good credit CU I don't I
don't take loans out for anything now
I'm never going back into debt so I I
think it's important to have that
conversation early on and set that
expectation and and don't don't confuse
your level of commitment or love or
caring or or Compassion or empathy
with with what they're doing uh don't
confuse that with the monetary
obligation of of doing something else
and so having a conversation about
whether or not you can afford it is
important and if they suggest going into
debt just say well no that doesn't align
with my values and and I know that none
of my friends or family would certainly
ask me to do something that is against
my
values our next question is from
Caitlyn I recently interviewed for a
position and got offered a job but it's
taking a $99,000 pay cut per year which
is pretty significant so I want to know
what you think someone should do when
they're trying to go after their dreams
do you think that it's worth it to take
that initial p cut to end up being in an
industry that you you think will make
you happy in the long run or do you
think you have to be more financially
Savvy um I do have student loan debt and
credit card debt and I've been able to
pay a pretty good chunk every month of
that uh and by taking this pay cut it
would significantly reduce the amount
that I can make payments on my credit
cards which is obviously a deterrent but
then again I want to be happy uh I want
to start making my way into a position
that will fulfill me in the in the end
game so you had me right up until the
the the debt part I I was so ready to
jump in and say yes so there are a few
questions here that I think will be
applicable to to a lot of different
people here um Caitlyn first off in
terms of of finances I'm going to send
you a copy of our book essential because
uh there's essay collection and it has
150 different essays 12 different
chapters one of the chapters is on
finances and I think it'll help point
you in the right direction in terms of
money so I'd love to send you a a copy
of that book but until you get that let
me let me try to answer a few two
different questions here you you have
three different questions I want to I
want to talk about first one I want to
talk about is should I switch careers or
or jobs and in our last podcast we
actually talked about the difference
between a a job a career and a mission
so if you haven't listened to that yet
because it you haven't it hasn't come
out yet um uh well by the time this
shows up on our podcast it will I'm
talking to the folks here on Twitter and
Periscope but um we we delineate between
a a job a career and a mission sounds to
me like you're moving from a career into
something that is your mission and that
is awesome but we we'll talk about what
the right decision is in a moment the
second question you're asking is about
well should I stay in this career for a
while and pay off some debt that that is
a really wonderful question because uh
uh it means that you're not just making
this knee-jerk reaction to go from one
place to another now the the the third
thing I want to talk about is about
happiness and I'm going to start there
you you you said because I want to be
happy I want you to realize something
that happiness isn't the
point living a meaningful life is the
point and happiness is an important
byproduct of that the problem where we
get caught is we often Chase happiness
and the way we Chase happiness is
through things through status through
trinkets through promotions through job
titles through sexual relationships you
know we we all of these ephemeral things
that aren't going to bring us lasting
contentment they'll bring us momentary
Joy but they're not useful for our
longterm and they're certainly not
useful for the the greater good of the
world around us and so they don't help
us grow they don't help us contribute
and so we feel the sense of discontent
and so meaningful life includes those
five values I mentioned
earlier but but the meaning of life is
growth and contribution am I growing am
I giving and and if I'm able to do that
ultimately happiness is going to be a
byproduct of that so I would much rather
search for meaning than Chase happiness
so so keep that in mind when you're
asking these questions is this going to
be meaningful for me that will lead to
you to happiness not in the moment not
in the ephemeral sense of happiness but
but a lasting contentment which will
mean happiness in the moment as well but
not just in the moment now in terms of
whether you should make this career
change or I would say change toward your
mission uh until you got to the debt
part I would I would tell you to ask
yourself this question if you were in
the opposite shoes if you're already in
this career that was or in this mission
that was really fulfilling you had the
sense of autonomy and purpose and
Mastery and and you were moving in the
right direction you felt like you were
growing you were giving it your all you
were passionate about it and it allowed
you to balance out your life in a way
that that was truly
meaningful would you want to switch
careers for $9,000 more a year and and
if so why C I certainly wouldn't in fact
when I was in the corporate world I was
a director of operations for 150 retail
stores which I know sounds really
impressive that was that that status uh
because I had this impressive job title
but I also didn't feel fulfilled I
didn't feel happy but I also wasn't
living a a meaningful life I wasn't
focused on my values I was focused on
earning a paycheck I was successful in
the monetary cents I was making a couple
$1,000 a year and when I walked away
from that I was making about 10% of what
I was making so a couple $1,000 to about
$27,000 when I when I walked away from
that corporate world but I found so much
more meaning in the life that that I was
experiencing afterward because I started
to live in accordance with my values my
short-term actions matched my long-term
values and it seems to me that's the
direction you're going in now I don't
know your specific situation Caitlyn in
terms of your debt so it may mean
sticking in out for a short period of
time and having a plan to pay off those
debts and I think that's okay unless you
don't have that that option to to stick
it out where you are for a while here's
a third option though is there something
else you can do to pay off those debts I
can tell you what I did I delivered
pizzas for a while um I got in my my
nice car put the Papa John's logo on top
of my car and delivered pizzas to pay
off my my credit cards you could
certainly do the same if you live in a
city that has Uber I think it's a great
way to to pay off uh your debts to be
Uber driver for a while if you have a
car that will allow you to do that to
deliver pizzas to do something else that
is going to allow you to still focus on
your passion but short term put yourself
in the situation allows you to pay off
your debts and once you pay off those
debts never go back never go back in the
debt because you want to maintain your
freedom and you want to maintain your
sense of of security and that real
security comes from getting rid of those
faux security those faux certainties
that the trinkets uh uh that the the
trinkets give give us in in the moment
our next question is from
Nina I have lived in several different
countries um several different cities
and each time I moved to a new place I
try to get rid of everything and I
literally want to live this hugely
minimalist life where I have X amount of
clothes x amount of books x amount of
furniture yet after a year I feel like
everything just accumulates all over
again and I don't want to have to wait
until the next time I move to another
city be it for life or for work to start
a new to start a fresh and I guess my
question is what can I do to get back to
that point of inspiration of tossing
everything even though I'm technically
not going anywhere yet so your journey I
is ever evolving and that's true for all
of us right we're going to get a to a
point where we feel like all right I've
simplified my life and now I'm done but
you're never done that's the cool thing
about this whole experience and I wrote
about this uh Nina I'm going to send you
a copy of our book everything that
remains it's my favorite book of
everything that we've done and I wrote
about my whole journey and what I
realized and and I wrote about this
toward the end is once I've simplified
my life there's always a New Horizon and
so you're always working toward this
ideal self and and you know for me I'm
34 years old I aspire to be much more
like my 35y old self or my 40-year-old
self or my 50-year-old self as I move
toward the Horizon there's going to be a
New Horizon and so as I simplify my life
now circumstances change I became a a
parent by proxy last year and and that
circumstance has allowed me to bring
more things into my life for sure and
question those things in a different way
and also work with other people my
partner Becca and and her daughter Ella
and and being willing to have you the
conversations I would have never had to
have by myself and so I'm going to
recommend a few just tips for you if if
you get into a moment where you're like
oh my gosh I'm so overwhelmed and I've
got all this extra stuff in my life and
I had simplified before but I've brought
a bunch of stuff in it's not add adding
value to my life ask yourself a few
questions start with this one how might
my life be better with less now if you
ask that question and you're honest with
yourself you're going to identify a
bunch of benefits maybe it means oh I
can travel more or my place will be
tidier or I won't have to clean as much
or I can regain control of my finances
or I can regain control of my time my
relationships my health health I'm going
to have more time to explore my
community I'm going to have more time
for me I'm going to be able to meditate
what are the benefits for you they're
going to be different for all of us and
what are the main benefits and focus on
those but by having less I'm focusing on
these because the point of getting rid
of the stuff isn't getting rid of the
stuff we clear the Clutter so we can
make room for what's truly important and
once you've asked that question take a
look at your stuff and start asking
another question does this add value to
my life and if you ask that question
enough of all of your things when I
started simplifying it took me about 8
months to radically simplify my life and
it's because I kept asking that question
over and over I'd look at each artifact
and say does this thing add value to my
life and ever after I asked that a bunch
of times over and over and over it
became less of a of a question and more
of a feeling and I was able to identify
does this serve a purpose for me does it
bring me joy and if not I had to be
willing to let go because I realized
that my willingness to let go meant that
those things could bring value to other
people's lives just because I wasn't
going to get value from it that doesn't
mean that someone else wouldn't so my
willingness to let go was really a
willingness to give value to other
people now if you want some tactics so
those are some strategies if you want
some tactics I'm going to recommend you
start with something that we call the
30-day minimalism game so if you've
cluttered your life up
again let's let's talk about this 30-day
minimalism game and you can see we just
posted a new article on our website
recently we had a a reporter up in
Canada uh up in Edmonton Alberta Canada
who did the the minimalism game posted a
video about it so you can go to the
minimalist.org
grapher and a reporter for the Edmonton
Journal and he documented his whole
process for this 30-day this 30-day
period where he was letting go of all
these things and he he he really
considered it to be an episonic
experience I feel like he he said it was
cathartic and letting go let him learn a
lot about himself and it may have been
terrifying at times but it was also very
meaningful and freeing and that's what I
want you to experience is something
that's that is freeing and it's freeing
because you know you're headed toward
something better better finances better
relationships whatever it may be you've
got that that ideal objective that ideal
life in mind that Horizon in line in
mind and you're just getting that stuff
out of the way that allows you to to
move uh uh toward that Horizon much more
quickly and and so once you've played
the the minimalism game basically all
you have to do is you grab a friend
family member cooworker you start at the
beginning of a new month so first day of
the month you each get rid of one item
on the second day of the month two items
third day of the month three items so it
starts out really easy but you get some
momentum as as you you you go on that's
what you need to start but it gets much
more difficult by day 15 where you're
getting rid of 15 items on day 15 16
items on day 16 and and then you're like
wow this is more and more difficult now
since you're playing with a friend it
makes a little more fun because
decluttering is I think is pretty boring
some people find it fun and that's great
I think it's boring and the way to make
it more fun is with a little friendly
competition so whoever goes the longest
in in this month wins if you both make
it to the end of the month you both won
because you've both gotten rid of about
500 items and that's a hell of a start
we've had a lot of people who keep
playing past day 31 so on day 35 they're
getting rid of 35 items so forth and so
on it's really up to you to determine
your own rules and make it your own
recipe for a a more meaningful game but
we've had tens of thousands of people
you can check out the hashtag for that
it's say # men's game m i ns
G on Twitter and especially on Instagram
tons of photos there you can share your
own photos of of the journey and so
that's one tactic if you want to just
dive in you can do what Ryan did he did
a packing party which is something I
wish I would have done he packed up all
his stuff pretended as if he was moving
he spent the next 21 days unpacking only
the items he needed and he found that he
wasn't using didn't find Value in about
80% of his stuff so he sold and donated
pretty much all of it and so I think
that's uh the more aggressive way to
tackle your clutter and that's great and
the third thing I would do before you
bring anything new into your life start
questioning those things UPF front
that's how you keep your life from
getting cluttered because the easiest
way to organize your stuff is to get rid
of most of it and to get rid of most of
it also means to bring fewer things in
as you move
forward our next question is from
Kristen I've got an issue with my
boyfriend's mother um she's a giver and
every time we visit which is about
weekly we end up coming home with
something and often times it's great
because she sends us home home with
groceries or other consumables however
more often than not because of her
volunteer position at a local strip shop
we end up with a lot of things we don't
need and I know she gives us things as a
way of showing her love for us but I'm
so frustrated my relationship with her
is too new at this point for me to tell
her flat out what I think of her gifts
but I've explained minimalism to her and
how it makes my life better yet she
still sends bags full of unwanted items
home with us so I was just wondering if
you had any advice on that point it's an
interesting question the first thing is
yes you do need to have a conversation
but not with her that would be the worst
thing you could do is have a
conversation with your boyfriend's
mother the conversation that needs to be
had needs to be with your boyfriend you
two need to get on the same page here
and he then needs to have a conversation
with his mother and that's what's
important and if he were the one calling
in I'd be giving him the same advice and
and if it was your mother that was
forcing stuff on him now the
conversation need he needs to have isn't
about don't get me stuff it's about what
you're getting instead of getting stuff
can we get experiences can we share
something together there's this concert
that me and my boyfriend really want to
go to let's go to that you know all all
of these these experiences you can have
and that way she can still feel like
she's contributing because that's what
she she's trying to do here she's
thinking that giftgiving physical gift
giving is a love language but really the
real love language is contribution and
so what she's trying to do is contribute
to you in some way show that she cares
about you by giving it's just the gifts
that you're getting they aren't bringing
any sense of joy in fact it's the
opposite they're draining the Joy from
your life and stressing you out because
you have this point of contention right
now and if uh if your boyfriend has a
good relationship with his mother which
it sounds like he has a great one then
it's going to be easy for him to have
this conversation as long as he
positions it as here's what we would
like going forward not here's what we
don't want but here's what we we do want
if you if you phrase it in a positive
way you are going to to get some
positive results from that and because
uh you're in Poria Illinois one
experience you can have is uh see our
documentary uh the closest one to you we
have one in uh Springfield but I tell
you what I think we still have Sean we
have some tickets left to um our tour
stop there in Chicago Let's uh let's go
ahead and send her uh some tickets for
her and her boyfriend uh this is for
Kristen and and we'll be able to answer
her questions in person maybe she maybe
they can bring uh the mother as well so
let's send three tickets if if we can
and and bring the mother and we're happy
to to dish out some hugs while you're
there also we'll be in Chicago in in May
and we hope you can join us and if you
can't we'll we'll send you some tickets
to one of the other screenings we have a
bunch of them in Illinois right now all
right uh I would love to hear what you
have to say about any of these these
voice mail so if if um you have a
comment or minimalism tip for any of the
people who called in today or just a
random minimalism tip in general uh you
can give us a call
97839 we will air our favorite comments
and tips on the next episode and if your
voicemail is selected then we will send
you a copy uh an autograph copy of one
of our books either essential or
minimalism live a meaningful life or my
personal favorite everything that
remains I just want to say thank you
real quick to everyone who has left uh
amazing amazing iTunes comments for us
we really appreciate it and um we're
going to keep reading some of our
favorites on air so uh keep your
positive honest but also very creative
iTunes comments uh
coming this one is from sweet cherish
cat ever since I discovered minimalism
through the minimalist blog not
surprisingly I have been inspired to
declutter my life in all aspects and and
return to simple meaningful living
Joshua and Ryan do not preach their
method within their podcast but approach
the subject and apply their recipe to
real life subject matter as if we all as
if we are all just a couple of friends
sitting in a quiet coffee shop oh that
that's exactly what I want to do here
and that's why I'm doing this thing on
Periscope right now sweet cherish cat
thank you the by the way the um the
title of this one was advertisements
suck but this podcast doesn't um usually
we start off our podcast I didn't start
it off today with some sort of
disclaimer that this is 100%
advertisement free if you do want to
support the podcast you can go to the
minimal. Donate um sweet cherish cat
thank you I'm going to send you a copy
of everything that remains and anyone
else who has a comment feel free to get
really creative with it we really
appreciate it um we read these comments
not to be self- congratulatory uh we're
grateful that we're able to contribute
and and it does mean a lot that that you
all are getting something from it so
thank you so much for uh the value you
add to our lives and thank you for
giving us this this small opportunity to
contribute to your lives in in some way
if you do want to support the podcast
you can just go to the minimal. Donate
but uh there's no requirement there we
we do have a lot of you who are
certainly uh supporting us and the rest
of you if you can't afford that you
absolutely get it for free and uh
advertisement free which is also
important to me all right let's move on
to our hashtag askthe minimalists
lightning round where we answer uh
questions from social media we are on
Twitter and Instagram and also on
Periscope right we're on Periscope atth
minimalists for all three of those
platforms Twitter Instagram and
Periscope atth minimalists and we're at
facebook.com slthe minimalist I'm going
to be answering questions from all of
those platforms right now and our first
question which I have have right here is
from ly Lee these are long questions
today I pulled a lot of them from from
Facebook and then the shorter ones are
from Twitter and Instagram let's see
here Lindley she's in uh Wilmington
Delaware last episode you talked about
sentimental items while I have very few
there are things I'm not sure I should
keep or if it's okay to let go of I have
this this huge piece of paper that
represents the 4 and A2 years I spent in
college and the thousands of dollars
spent on education which I'm not using
it's not like I'm a doctor and I need to
hang in on a wall to show my credentials
or anything so I don't see a reason for
keeping my diploma is it okay to shred
it I mean it's just a piece of paper
right uh Lin Lee yes it is just a piece
of paper and it sounds to me like you're
looking for permission and so you can
keep this recording anytime uh you're
feeling doubts and anyone else can keep
this recording as well you have
permission to let go but you don't you
don't need my permission you can have it
if you want what you need is your
permission and you have to be willing to
let go and you're right it is a piece of
paper and even if you were a doctor I
can't tell you that anytime I've I've
been to a doctor and I've been to a lot
of doctors in the last year Sean can
attest to um I I've been doing a lot of
physical therapy and stuff for my back
and I can't tell you a single time I've
walked in the doctor's office said I
need to see his credentials on the wall
that's going to help me determine you
know whether or not I'm going to find
this a good experience no I I I don't
need to see his diploma on the wall what
I need to see is what's his bedside
manner is is it congenial to my way of
of thinking and learning and interaction
and and the same thing with you this
piece of paper is not you you are you
and the best way to show who you are is
through your consistent actions not
through hanging a piece of paper on the
wall so yeah is it okay to shred it yeah
absolutely if you're feeling uh a bit
apprehensive treid acious about that
then you know what take a picture of it
first that way you'll be able to store
it digitally you don't even have to take
a picture of it you can scan it as well
you can do what I did it was called
called a scanning party which you can
read about at the minimalist.org
uh but Lin Ley I'll also send you a
couple tickets to your closest screening
of minimalism our documentary um anyone
else can find that at minimalism
film.com
slatch you can find your closest theater
there Sarah says I'm wondering if 's a
market out there for uh for communities
to share appliances and tools for
example my neighbors try to find try to
help clear snow from other drive from
others driveways if folks don't own snow
blowers or shovels that's really nice of
them that's a hell of a community that
you live in there uh have you run into
communities like this I'd love to get
rid of larger tools and appliances that
are cluttering our garage but would also
like to make those things available to
others to borrow when need needed yeah
there's a few few that I'm aware of two
in particular uh you can go to
freecycle.org and we'll put that in the
show notes as well everything else I'm
talking about today Sean we'll we'll go
ahead and throw in the show Notes too
any links or essays or things that I'm
mentioning will be in the show show
notes at the minimal lists.com
podcast but um yeah in terms of tools
free cycle is is a great way free
cycle.org and then um we were in
Albuquerque for a tour stop a few years
ago and we had a guy come up to us and
say I use Craigs list is my storage
locker if I need a chainsaw I just go to
Craigslist find a chainsaw and then and
you know pay 20 25 bucks for it or
whatever it may be and then when he is
done with that chainsaw he'll put it
back in his storage locker which is
Craigslist and he'll re repost it and
resell it on Craigslist and for big uh
appliances like that you're going to use
once a year uh or or tools I should say
not appliances would fit too um that's
certainly something you can do I'd love
to hear what other people say too I'm
sure there are other websites and apps
out there uh that you can share with me
so you can give us a call and leave a
comment on our voicemail 406 21978 39
love to hear your tips on that too a
star in Alberta Canada star asks my
question involves sharing space with
someone who is on the journey but
struggling a bit uh we've been
completely overhauling Our Lives the
last 6 months getting rid of anything
that isn't a value re-evaluating our
family values and moving toward a
quieter slower existence with the
emphasis on building our relation
relationships with ourselves and our
kids the only thing that scares my
husband is getting rid of internet at
the house
aha I am there right now ready to cancel
cable and internet and save that saves
us 150 bucks a month to do so but he
still enjoys playing his video games I
I'm reading this with scorn cuz it
sounds like he still likes his video
games here here comes he plays video
games that require an internet
connection for streaming I appreciate
your podcast where you talk about going
to cof coffee shops to use internet Etc
and it became a light bulb moment for me
there is so much free internet why am I
paying for it well there's no such thing
as free internet we'll talk about that
in a moment it's like saying they
getting free college education there's
no such thing as free um uh uh there's
so much free internet why am I paying
for it uh I've been having a lot of
conversations about about what it is
about the games what their purpose is
for him oh that's probably a bad way to
approach it uh he read he readily mits
he doesn't like how manipulative the
video games are in respect to keeping
players hooked uhhuh and he agrees that
it's wasted time okay uh that's good so
he agrees with you there and even
reading a book has more value sometimes
it does yeah um there's actually there's
some neuros I'm so I used to be very
anti- video game The Last you know 15 20
years of my life I used to love it as as
a pacifier in my teens and early 20s but
um uh there's there's a lot of actually
Neuroscience now that shows some video
games especially uh like puzzle piece
kind of games like Tetris um can help
your your cognitive function improve
even games like like Call of Duty aren't
inherently bad I I've never played Call
of Duty myself but I know what it is and
I've seen other people play it and there
are there's a book um called super
better I've mentioned before but we'll
throw a link to that in the show notes
as well especially people who have
received brain damage or trying to or
who have bra brain damage trying to
receive treatment um um there are video
games that can help with that but you're
right it it's very it can be a pacifier
sometimes let me continue with her
question which is the longest of them
and I would say that he is an equal
partner in deciding how our family is
changing the
future uh we are moving toward good what
can I do to support his journey in a way
that respects his needs as well as my
own I'm more of a cold turkey kind of
person so cutting internet all at once
is what works for me but I'm hesitant to
do do it if my husband isn't ready um
suggestions yes let let put your money
where your mouth is here if you really
are the type of cold turkey person just
have him change the Wi-Fi password that
way you can't get on the internet but
your household still can you don't want
to deprive others in your household
that's not a way to get them to follow
you you want to lead by example so by
removing that connection yourself and
and and being militant about it for
yourself what you're going to do is
allow allow them to see the benefits not
just the application not just the action
of removing the internet so what you're
referring to is a few years ago when I
moved uh to a new small I was trying to
pay off all my debt so I moved to this
small apartment in Dayton Ohio which you
can see at the minimalist.org
you in Dayton Ohio which is a a
relatively decent apartment for one
person and um you know I I got rid of
internet for a month and as a an
experiment and it was the most
productive month I ever had and I ended
up never getting internet at home and
that was maybe four years ago I think it
was back in in
2011 yeah and I never went back because
it was so productive in fact I I live in
Montana now I still don't have internet
at home now one of the benefits was I I
did save about 30 bucks a month 40 bucks
a month 50 bucks a month uh I don't even
know what internet cost it was probably
$80 a month now uh for good internet in
some places 100 bucks a month um I did
save that money but that's not why I did
it uh money was not the primary driver
and generally it's not the primary
driver for doing what I want to do
unless I'm trying to get out of debt
trying to get out of that crater right
and so I found that I um I I I was more
interested
in re regaining and retaining my focus
and internet was getting in the way I
would get lost in that Bermuda Triangle
of YouTube and Instagram and Facebook
and actually it wasn't even Instagram at
the time it was Twitter and and I would
get stuck in in that in that Loop and so
I now keep my phone in one very specific
place as soon as I get home it goes on a
charging dock and anytime I need to use
it I have to get up from wherever I am
and and go to that charging dock to send
a text message or a phone call or
whatever and and so I would encourage
that as an experiment and you may find
that you're actually depriving yourself
if you get rid of internet for a month
give it a month though if if you're
really wanting to do it and and you can
go elsewhere I at the office right now
so I have internet access here I plan my
internet time now and that's certainly
something you can do whether it's a
coffee shop or we have an office here uh
so we do pay for internet here uh we pay
for this office and it it comes to it's
part of that that expense and so uh I
didn't do it because it was free saving
a little bit of money at home because if
I had internet at home right now I'd be
spending a little bit more money on that
uh was a nice benefit but it wasn't the
reason I did it I wanted to do it
because I wanted to start focusing on on
my value vales and I found this was
often getting in the way of that Jasmine
in
Minneapolis writes focusing on
relationships is a major component of
the minimalist lifestyle but how would
you approach a toxic relationship with a
very close family member sometimes
cutting even parents or siblings out of
life is necessary but I'm struggling to
reconcile eliminating a toxic
relationship versus using my additional
time and resources to rebuild that
relationship
interesting so I wrote an essay uh about
about this topic called goodbye fake
friends you could find that at
theminimalists.com
fake also in the show notes to this
episode and you know what I I haven't
read anything today so let me go ahead
and read that and then we'll talk a
little bit about uh Jasmine's question
here dear fake friends from my past when
I walked away from a successful career 3
years ago you thought I was crazy even C
crazier when I said I wanted to
cultivate my passion pursue my dream
writing it's all right there's no need
to to deny it now save your apolog
apologies I'm not looking for one scores
of you my ostensible friends talked
behind my back the Grapevine is not
self-contained so yes I heard the
terrible things you said about me you
said I was Dumb Out of Touch Too
idealistic
you gossiped you told people I'd lost my
mind I was an idiot you said lost I'd be
broke and alone in no
time it was
upsetting gut-wrenching and
heart-rending to hear the vitri all I
thought you were different I thought we
were different I thought we were friends
you my lip service friends told me it
was impossible if could people could
make a living from their their passions
you said then everyone would be doing it
I was making a mistake a horrible
decision you said I'd reg regret giving
up the money the status the ostensible
success my plan would never work it's
evident now you were projecting your own
fears hoping I would fail so your flawed
idea of success would remain
unblemished I don't regret it my change
in lifestyle it all worked out and then
some my life is better now substantially
better be it money passion Health growth
contribution my life has improved
exponentially even my friends are better
my real friends although they may have
not fully understood my decisions at the
time they supported me through the
transition real support they encouraged
me cheered me on offered help when I
needed it it took took this radical
change to recognize my real friends and
to recognize those just hanging on
because I had an impressive job title or
the shiny things they wanted without the
facade of a big paycheck or an oversized
house I made new friends people whose
interests values and beliefs align with
mine wonderful people who care about me
for me not for what's printed on my
business card so goodbye fake friends of
old I'm walking away for good and you
won't be able to catch up before I go
though I want to thank you for teaching
me one of life's most important lessons
you can't change the people around you
but you can change the people around
you so let me just expand on that real
quick um you can't change the people
around you but you can change the people
around you sometimes I find it necessary
to surround myself with people whose
values are similar to mine we may have
radically different personalities we may
have radically different beliefs uh I'm
not a particularly religious person but
many of my my closest friends are uh
Christians or or P pastors even or
Buddhists um or radical atheist I
wouldn't consider myself an atheist
either I I I just I don't have a term
for what I am really and and I don't I
don't need one but you might have a
radically different belief template but
we're getting to it's just a different
road to get us to the same place it gets
us to our same values and and people I
surround myself with now are much more
focused on on contributing they're most
much more focused on growing they're
they're focused on being the best
version of themselves and that means a
lot of times I had to let go of crappy
relationships in my life so Jasmine yes
I would encourage you to reallocate your
time to more meaningful relationships
those are harder to find but they're
easier easier to find than ever uh
because we have more tools at our
disposal whether that's the internet you
can go to minimalist.org that's the and
we do have a a Minneapolis chapter and
we have a hundred chapters in fact all
over the world eight eight different
countries uh where we connect
open-minded like-minded people it's
absolutely free we don't want anything
from you it's just a way that we can
contribute and and have meetup groups
free local meetup groups in a 100
different cities so you can find those
at minimalist.org you can go to
meetup.com
you can go to Twitter which I've met a
lot of my closest friends on Twitter I I
know that sounds like it's hard to
believe until you actually start to do
it and what you'll find is you have only
24 hours in a day so really it's not
about just pushing those friends out of
your life it's about reallocating your
time to people who share similar values
to you and sometimes you do however have
to have difficult conversations if
people gossip to you they gossip about
you and that's a lesson I learned and if
people in my life life start to gossip
to me I I realize that they're probably
also saying things behind my back and
and those are relationships that I'm
willing to let go of and that means
spending less time or no time at all
with those people because my time is
very important we have three types of
relationships we wrote about this in our
book uh minimalism live a meaningful
life it's in the relationship chapter of
that the the types of relationships we
have are primary secondary and and uh
the tertiary relationships or the uh
would call the relationships on the
periphery the most important
relationships in our life those are the
primary relationships you can count
those on one hand usually if you're an
introvert like me you still have a few
digits left uh if you're a Catholic you
might have count them on two hands
because you have a big family but you
know what if it those are the people
you're closest to and and the secondary
relationships those are still people you
love people you care about extended
family close friends uh co-workers you
really really love and then you have
these these the third layer of
relationships the the tertiary
relationship sh the people on the
periphery and co-workers acquaintances
networking buddies friends in the
community uh uh just different people
they're still good people and you care
about them but they relationships in
your life I found that for the longest
time I was spending so much time in that
third tier that I didn't have enough
time for the people closest to me and so
in order to change that I had to rep
prioritize my relationships the people
who were in that first tier I had to
start treating them like they were in
the first tier and prioritizing putting
all of my time and attention toward them
first then whatever time was left over
spinning that with the the secondary
tier and then anything that was left
over from that then moving on to the the
tertiary tier and so you're going to
have to find that PE people will change
tiers over time I know my best friend
from the the first grade still isn't my
best friend although uh the interesting
thing is my my best friend from high
school is still my best friend now I
mean with Ryan and so some people stick
around in their same tears in fact I
although in my early 20s Ryan moved to
that that secondary tier or even the
tertiary tier for for a period of time
and we wrote about that in the same book
where you know we he went One Direction
After High School I went a separate
Direction and that was okay it's not
like we we didn't like each other or
anything like that we we just sort of
drifted apart for a while but then we
drifted back together and that's the
cool thing is if you're deliberate about
how you change these tears you can
allocate your time to the people who are
most important to you and that will
allow you to to weed out the people who
no longer share your values sometimes
however it does require sitting down and
having a conversation with someone and
saying look this relationship is no
longer adding value to My Life um here's
what needs to change I don't need you to
change but in our relationship here's
what's going to have to change in order
for me to keep this relationship in my
life it's a difficult conversation to
have but it's certainly one that's
worthwhile our next question is from
Casey I am in the process of
decluttering but I am having a hard time
letting go of items not for sentimental
reasons but for environmental reasons I
want the stuff gone but I feel so guilty
throwing everything away I donate as
much as possible to Goodwill but uh some
stuff I am stuck on isn't it isn't
really fit to be donated but I don't
want to create more trash either uh do
you have any resources for donating
recycling or repurposing items uh or any
thoughts to help uh reconcile my
cluttering and zero waste tendency my
decluttering and zero waste Tendencies
uh yeah so so first off uh you can go to
donationtown.org there's a bunch of
resources there in terms of donating now
um I just want to be clear here Ryan and
I advocate responsible decluttering
responsible Letting Go you often hear us
use the word trash something but we
don't mean it literally like yeah I just
want to trash all my stuff or trash all
your St no like that's not we don't mean
like run a dumpster and throw your
things in it what we mean is letting go
of it and and just like on your computer
you know often you have the the trash
bin I'm looking at mine right now it
just says trash it's not literally trash
it's not filling up a landfill somewhere
however I also want you to realize this
is not a binary solution this isn't zero
I'm not an advocate of zero waste either
I'm an advocate of of much much much
less waste and and the way that we
produce less was in our lifetime is by
consuming less going forward and and
that's that's what's important the
things we have now they can you can do
three things with try to sell them
especially big big ticket items that
help me get out of debt especially if
you're in debt you can find a way to
sell them on Craigslist or eBay or a
bunch of different apps that people have
recommended on on different episodes and
if you have another way to to to donate
or sell your stuff I'm I'm looking
forward to hearing about it on our
voicemail line uh but you can also so
you can sell your stuff you can donate
it uh whether it's the Goodwill um you
you can donate it to a local place as
well you can find from donation town.org
I avoid donating to um Salvation Army
because their their values don't align
with mine uh personally uh there's
some they've done some some pretty
egregious things it doesn't mean the
people the or everyone at the
organization's bad but they've done some
uh pretty egregious things toward uh
non-traditional marriage I guess you
would call it and anyone who who who
lives a a sort of non-traditional or or
uh a lifestyle that that isn't a just
heterosexual lifestyle um and so that uh
I find th those actions deplorable and
so I I go out of my way to support
places that do align with my values I've
had people complain to me before because
I donate I do donate to Goodwill
sometimes they say but the CEO makes a
million dollars a year well I'm I'm not
against money and and so if a CE CEO
does a phenomenal job of creating value
for uh a bunch of different communities
around the world I don't think that's
inherently bad that that he he makes
money I certainly don't make a million
dollars a year and that's not my goal in
life but if he's creating far more value
than that uh I don't think it's
inherently bad that said I do go out of
my way to support local uh places much
more and so we have a bunch of
organizations here in Missoula we have a
donation Warehouse we have some thrift
shops here that I'll donate donate
clothes to and and you can find
alternatives to to Goodwill as well and
so the third thing is yeah sometimes you
do have to trash things and sometimes
their their home is in in the trash but
that's far and few between I found that
far less than 10% of the things that I
owned actually ended up making it into
the trash when I was decluttering now
again it's not advocating for a a zero
waste lifestyle but if I were to take
100% of my things and throw it away
that's going to produce far more waste
than 3 to 10% of my things that actually
ended up in in the the trash so it's
about being more deliberate and the few
things we do trash yes I understand that
that that is going to take its toll if
everyone um throws away everything they
have but if you're removing a few bits
of of clutter that you've really
determined can't make it anywhere else
they're not going to add value to anyone
else's life and you're going to throw it
away that's okay once you've made that
deliberate decision so my my takea away
from this would be make the most
deliberate decision possible with those
things sell it donate it and if you must
because no one else is going to get
value from it then you can decide to
trash it and then you can feel good
about letting it go because you were
very intentional about that
decision Jesse asks silverware and
dishes should we just have one per
family member what about guests I um
remember growing up I had some friends
had this large Catholic Family um uh
back in Dayton Ohio and uh they the dad
was like a total prankster and so they
had six boys it was uh Jim and Tara and
and their six boys and they'd have eight
place settings around the table well one
of the boys would bring a date over you
know when they were growing up in high
school or whatever and and to play a
joke they would just set out eight eight
plates still and the dad Jim would just
scoop all of the the green beans and the
meatloaf or whatever right onto the
table and eat right there from the table
um no I'm not advocating that you do
that uh but there are solutions to
everything maybe the question maybe have
hard to rephrase the question let's say
you have enough for four guests right
now so you already have you have four
people in your household I have no idea
how many people you have in your
household Jesse let's say you have four
people in your household you have four
extra sets for four more guests what
happens if you have five guests come
over over well you don't have enough
right what happens if you have 10 guests
come over you eventually you're going to
reach a threshold you don't want to plan
for every scenario is my point now me I
have a few extra plates a few extra
bowls uh but I also realize that I I
have a stack of uh compostable plates as
well so if I have extra guests that come
over we'll do one of two things I'll
break out a compostable plate if I
absolutely need it because I've used up
all of my dish wear or um and I I've had
a a lot of people get a lot of value
from this uh
byop you bring your own plate if we're
having a big dinner or something bring
your own plate it's just like you're
going to bring some food as well I've
had people bring their own plate uh we
did this for for Christmas uh two years
ago and we didn't have enough plates for
everyone that we we brought over Ry and
I were were living together at the time
and um we we just had people bring their
own plates and it worked out just fine
and people actually thought it was kind
of cool and they liked it and they
thought oh that's a good idea I should
do this too so so no have what's enough
for you and you have you have to answer
that question yourself ask yourself what
what is enough and and once you
determine what enough is for you don't
try to plan for every scenario you're
not planning for the in-laws to come
over and then your parents to come over
and they're going to bring their dog and
oh what about uh what about my great
aunt is she going to show up this year
you're not going to plan for every
scenario so for plan for what happens on
a daily basis what's likely going to
happen in a short period of time maybe
use the 9090 rule is it has it happened
in the last 90 days is it going to
happen in the next 90 days and if not
then then you know what once in a blue
moon you might have to break out the
combustible uh plates you might have to
to to have someone bring their own plate
or something and that's totally fine
they're not there because they love how
great your plates look they're there
because they want to share an experience
with you Connor in Toronto says hi I'm
16 years old I'm living in Toronto and I
listen to your podcast every week
awesome thank you um I want to know how
I can help my family adapt to my
minimalist lifestyle aha both my parents
like keeping old bills and trinkets and
other useless objects quote just in
case what should I do and how can I help
them adjust to how I want to
live
um you can't help someone who doesn't
want help for a person drowning in the
river be very careful to jump in after
them because they might drag you down
with them now I don't think that's the
case here with with Connor you can show
them the benefits ultimately that's what
that's the only thing you can do is show
them how the your minimalist lifestyle
is improving your life and they may pick
up a few ingredients from your recipe
and apply it to their own lives but if
they find Value and and all this other
stuff you're not going to be able to
change them and in fact I would
encourage you not to try to change them
you can help them only if they want help
so maybe the first question to ask is do
they want help and maybe you're going to
have to ask them that now it sounds to
me like maybe maybe there's some point
of of contention or discontent there and
maybe if the stuff is a point of
discontent then you can offer help maybe
that's a doorway into offering help and
expressing the benefits and then you can
start asking them those questions how
might your life be better with less help
them identify what the benefits are
going to be for them Conor you can also
bring both your parents to our tour stop
and to Toronto we're going to send you a
couple tickets to to that it's on June
1st in Toronto um we're going to more
than a dozen cities so join us there and
bring your parents and we'll answer
answer any questions they have hopefully
they'll enjoy the the documentary and
also the live version of the podcast
there in Toronto it's our last stop of
the tour Adam in Scotland asks do you
have a single personal quote that
resonates with you more than any other
quote I like Henry David thorough
in Walden he wrote it's not enough to be
busy the question is what are you busy
about and if I were to append that quote
I would say the question is what are you
focused on because busy is the opposite
of focus and to me it's the worst
four-letter word that we have in our
language we stay busy busy busy but we
don't accomplish anything we're
constantly checking our email and
Facebook and doing things that make us
feel produc Ive the ape the form of
productivity but aren't actually
productive to us at all and so I have
found that I like to be less busy and I
like to be more focused on what I'm
doing and so people ask me all the time
how do you get so much done because I do
weigh less now that sounds
counterintuitive but really means I
focus on less and I would have get more
meaningful things done as opposed to
just running around like a chicken with
his head cut off the rat race right the
thing about the rat race is if you win
the rat race you are still a rat and so
focus a lot more be busy a lot less
denesh asks what are your views on
religion as a
minimalist well Ryan and I have two
different views on minimalism so if
you're asking me I'm not particularly
religious and what the nice thing I
found about um minimalism is it
coincides with a bunch of different
religious beliefs we were in Mississippi
for our last tour and guy came up to us
afterward and gave us a big hug and said
you know what guys it's just so great to
see a couple guys out here spreading
Jesus's
message and I thought wow okay I that's
interesting there are definitely some
parallels there right absolutely in fact
um some of my friends are pastors and so
that makes sense we have similar values
okay and then we were in Seattle and and
and this woman came up to us afterwards
and she gives us a a big hug and she
goes I'm just so happy to see a couple
Buddhists out here spreading these
Buddhist maxims with the world I said
huh interesting a lot of parallels there
right and then uh denes we got an email
from someone who said you did you know
that Muhammad is the original minimalist
I said huh no I didn't know that but
that's interesting but I think it
actually goes back before Muhammad if
you go back and look at the stoics you
look at someone like epicus or cica or
Marcus aurelus you have all of these
different people who live radically
different lives in the case of epitus he
used to be a slave and he was focused on
intentional living or you had Marcus
Aurelius who was the most powerful most
wealthiest man in the world also asking
similar questions as a former slave a
broke person and so uh these stoics who
who uh espouse the virtues of of living
a more intentional life and so I find
that minimalism coincides with with any
set of religious beliefs because it it
is much more about these values and I
don't think that th I don't think those
values can be ascribed to any one
particular uh religion there's a lot of
overlap between all of them and while I
may not may not share your specific
beliefs we may have very similar values
PAB asks how different would your life
be if you were practicing minimalism
from birth it's interesting we're all
born the ultimate minimalists aren't we
we come out of the womb
naked and and uh it's interesting then
we turn into the opposite of a
minimalist pretty quick now not not just
with the the acquisition of stuff
although the stuff is forced onto us
right away from our parents right
because that's society we're in but
minimalism if you just take away that
word for a minute you talk about what it
is it's about being intentional
intentionalism is maybe another word for
it and if I'm being more intentional
with the stuff that I bring into my life
and with the decisions I make well
that's the opposite of a Todd
you know I was I was with Ella this
morning we we were putting a puzzle
together and all of a sudden she just
decided it was like these these building
blocks a puzzle all of a sudden she just
looked at it and thought it was curious
to knock the whole thing over and she's
2 years old and that's the opposite of
intention right we act on impulse and
then it's weird because we start to
learn that acting on impulse isn't the
best way to do because we act on impulse
it hurts others it isn't best for us
long term it isn't best for our
happiness it isn't best for the
happiness of others it isn't best for
the greater good to just act on impulse
but then of course as we we grow up and
and we again start acting on impulse we
this impulse manifests differently it's
not knocking the blocks over it's oh I'm
going to buy this thing that I saw at
the checkout line uh I'm going to
acquire this new object I'm going to
shop impulsively impulsive buying uh
impulsive decision making and that gets
us into a world of trouble as well and
so I think we're all born minimalists in
the sense that we we we don't have this
problem with consumption in fact it's
interesting I I was thinking about this
recently Ella just when we eat dinner
together she has this uh it's me and we
just have three chairs at this bar area
and we don't have a dining room there
anything like that there's nothing wrong
with the dining room but it's not like
Ella Ever looks us and says where's our
dining room like that is a construct we
we've been told that like that's a thing
that we're supposed to have and in many
cases it does augment our experience
it's it's a good tool but it's not a a a
requirement it's not a necessity uh and
so whenever we build a house or we do
anything that is uh uh sort of a
cultural norm we start having these
things in our documentary we interviewed
a a um a minimalist architect named
Frank and he he said he said to me when
we were recording the interview this
part didn't make the film but he was
talking about um when he builds a house
for someone he never asks them do you
want a dining room do you want a living
room how many bedrooms do you want
because you're going to get the standard
answers yes I want a living room I have
to have a living room and I have to have
a a dining room and a kitchen and I have
to have these things instead he asks how
do you live your life and he builds a
house around their life what's
appropriate for them and for some people
dining room is totally appropriate and
uh personally I prefer having a dining
room myself uh because I like that's
where I like to work more so than having
a separate office I like having a sort
of communal communal space where I can
work and but it's not a requirement for
everyone and so the question is what is
appropriate for your life and so if I
would have been a minimalist since birth
to answer P's question I would have
acted more intentionally throughout my
Lotus eating 20s and and I probably
would have made better decisions and
been farther along on a path now I'm
grateful for the experiences I've had
and learned but you often hear people
say I would never go back and change
anything well that's silly if you have
the experience of before if you're able
to retain the the experience and still
go back and change stuff yeah I would
change a lot I I would live more
intentionally I would be more in the
moment I'd be more focused I'd surround
myself with more supportive people who
are like-minded open-minded and have
have similar
values uh Lucia in Panama asks could you
comment on the importance of enjoying
being on your own instead of always
being surrounded by people um being
alone I love being alone I am an
introvert so I would answer this
question differently if I was Ryan Ryan
is an extreme extrovert and so he uh
loves being around people all the time
that's where he gets his energy from and
that's awesome for me I get drained by
being around people and and so I have to
recharge more frequently uh than him and
so I'm going to read an essay for you uh
last one I will read today this one is
called alone time you can find it in the
show notes to this as well I'm walking
through a city in the Deep South today
alone but not lonely I used to think
there was something wrong with me
throughout my 20s I followed societal
Norms doing all the things you're
supposed to do to be a normal
functioning member of society going out
with co-workers after work spending
every evening and weekend with friends
killing time with vapid Small Talk
always engaged always on never
alone but this constant interaction wore
me out often I wasn't Pleasant to be
around it felt oddly
alone to never be
alone then as my 20s twilighted I
discovered I was more affable when I
carved out time for myself after all I'm
an intj there's a link here in the essay
as to what an inj is it's a type of
Personality uh but don't worry this
isn't a platitudinal reminder to make
time for yourself right rather it's a
reminder to embrace your
individualism your personality today I
spend copious amounts of time by myself
in fact I don't know anyone who spends
more time alone than me at least 80% of
my time is spent solo walking writing
exercising reading ruminating in the
process I've enjoyed I've learned to
enjoy The Sound of Silence to sit quiet
quietly and hear what's going on not
just around me but inside
myself yet the greatest benefit of
prolonged Solitude is that when I do
decide to immerse myself in social
situations be at a dinner with friends a
date or on tour I'm pretty awesome to be
around not only do I benefit from my
alone time but everyone around me
benefits too we all get the best version
of me I'm able to burst into social
situations with stored energy which
actually makes most people believe I'm
an extrovert since I'm able to engage at
a high level and employ active listening
humor and intellectually stimulating
conversation I don't however recommend
more alone time or more social time to
anyone it's not one size fits all so
what works for me may not work for you
take Ryan for example as an ENFP there's
also a link there to to what that means
his personality is nearly the obverse of
mine he spends more time around people
than anyone else I know he's the life of
the party naturally charismatic funny
and
likable uh By Nature he's always on as
an extrovert he actually gets his energy
from other people and time alone
exhausts him but classifying his
approach or my Approach as the right or
wrong approaches misses the point both
approach Roes can be right or wrong
depending on your personality which of
course is a Continuum even I in my in my
extroverted ways would hate to be
sentenced to Perpetual solitary
confinement just as Ryan in his Charming
extroversion occasionally needs a break
from his socialite lifestyle
ultimately whether introvert or
extrovert man or woman young or old I
recommend learning more about yourself
once you better know yourself you can
grow by easing into your discomfort
Zone um I also have at the end of that
essay you can find a a Myers Briggs Test
personality test by learning more about
myself I've been able to improve my
interactions with other people so
learning more about my own personality
it allows me to interact better with the
world around me I would encourage you to
to uh do the same thing and so alone
time for me is important but uh Lucia in
in Panama I'm not going to prescribe
aone time to you what I'm going to say
is learn your personality learn more
about yourself and learn what the
appropriate amount of alone time is for
you uh my partner uh beex she is an
introvert as well she's not nearly as
introverted as I am but she's pretty
introverted but she doesn't need as much
alone time as me and and she needs more
uh more time around more people and
that's great and and learning that
allows her to be the best version of
herself as well our last question is
from Dan Conrad in Washington
DC what would you tell your 18-year-old
self I think it's a great place to end
actually right so so Dan let me send you
a couple tickets to our DC tour stop
which actually might be close to sold
out at this point I think we're doing
two two screenings there so you may get
tickets to the the second one uh before
I answer Dan's question though uh I'm
going to just do a quick version of our
added value segment of of the podcast
this is where usually Ryan and I will
endorse something or or recommend
something that has added value to our
lives recently or maybe an activity
we're doing or something like that I am
going to recommend donating not to our
podcast but donating to places that uh
add value to your life in some way I
just went through and did my latest
round of doing this so I listen to a
bunch of different podcasts whether it's
Sam Harris or Radio Lab or uh Rob Bell
or the brilliant idiots or there man I
listen to dozens of podcasts you can see
my list of some of my favorites at uh
theminimalists.com
FP which stands for favorite podcasts FP
uh and what I did recently is anyone
that has an opportunity for me to donate
to them I go through and donate a few
bucks or in some case where I get
immense value from it I will donate you
what would I pay for this podcast I I
recently donated a couple hundred bucks
to to Sam Harris's podcast um because
because I get immense value from that
over the course of a year is it worth uh
200 bucks I've listened to it for 2
years now is it worth you know $100 a
year to me yeah I would probably pay
that I I get immense value from from a
lot of these but a lot of them I'll just
go donate two bucks three bucks five
bucks and it adds up for me but I get
immense value from those things that I
don't have to pay a subscription or
anything like that so find something
that adds value to your life whether
it's a podcast or a blog or something
and see if there's a way to contribute
and even if it's not a way to contribute
to them directly what are some of the
Charities or causes that they contribute
to as well Ryan and I Thanks to uh help
from you all were able to build an
element school last year we were able to
fund a high school last year we were
able to um build some clean water wells
in in maloi which was amazing I mean
literally life saving and and so we've
been able to do a lot of things like
that because uh a lot of you have been
willing to to support our efforts in
contributing to the world around us so
find a way to contribute that's what I'm
going to recommend and I'm going to
recommend that uh you do the same thing
finding a way to to contribute to the
things that add value to your life and a
few things of what's going on with us
what we a segment we call right here
right now I already mentioned minimalism
film.com you can find uh our tour you
can find the trailer which is amazing I
hope you've checked it out already and
you can find where it's playing in a
theater near you over at minimalism
film.com and then you just click on see
the film and you can find that there
also every Tuesday in uh March and April
of 2016 we are doing Tuesdays with the
minimalist it's where Ryan and I get on
Periscope and Twitter live for about an
hour and do lightning round question and
answer session it's a live video
broadcast where Ryan and I will answer
your questions live on Twitter and
Periscope we are atth minimalists also
I'm teaching a writing class as many of
you know but I have a one-day Workshop
many of you can't uh spare the time to
do a four-week writing class with me
online if you can great you can find
details of that how to write better. org
but if you want a one-day Workshop I had
hundreds of people attend this one last
month and so um I'm doing another one
June 26 2016 it's a limited seating you
can find all the details at how to write
better. org and um Sean this will be the
section where you can paste in I've got
some voicemail comments here um you can
paste all of those in and the final edit
of this so I will pause right now and
let you all listen some comments and
minimalism tips from our uh
listeners hey Josh and Ryan this is Paul
from Dallas Texas I wanted to call and
leave a comment about your sentimental
podcast you guys talked about um Jim
Morrison and those guys that sort of
dropped all of
their info or all of their information
that they had um all of their journals
and stuff that they built up I want to
say that George Carlin also did that as
well he scrapped all of his material for
a year and that gave him a totally blank
slate and it forced him to work harder
in order to build that up hello this is
tyranny in Oregon I follow you guys on
Facebook the minimal. and now I'm really
enjoying your podcast this is a followup
question for podcast episode number
three during the lightning round there
was a question about making decisions on
getting rid of books that made me think
of this suggest question I think a great
future podcast topic would be about free
public resources for books and media
such as the public library it is curious
to me how many people I query about
their local libraries do not even own a
library card our smallish town library
has endless books movies music online
audiobooks Kindle book loans online free
downloads online and iPad magazine reads
online movies all for free why own a lot
of books and media when you can just
borrow or download it for free from your
library hi this is Joe I'm from the
Dayton Ohio area I was just calling
about the sentimentals uh podcast I just
heard and one comment I had on one of
the first um callers that you aired she
had some heirlooms family heirlooms that
her daughter liked but she really had no
value for them or use for them and I had
one idea that I think could be mentioned
is to maybe take those items to a
jeweler um some kind of artistic Jeweler
that could recreate using that material
something that she would use um because
obviously she holds some value to it if
she hasn't thrown it out yet uh if you
have a a voicemail comment or question
for us 406 219 7839 we'd love to hear
your questions especially your comments
we air far more um uh comments than we
do questions we we just get a ton of
questions and so if if you have tips for
our our listeners we'd love to hear your
tips we're always looking for for new
tips Ryan and I don't have all the
answers but uh collectively between the
hundreds of thousands of people who
listen to this and and and Ryan and
myself we may be able to come up with
most of the answers which is pretty
awesome so thanks for sharing your tips
and you can just give us a call and Dan
your question what would you tell your
18-year-old
self love people and use things because
the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all I'll see you
next
time every little thing you think that
you need every little thing you think
that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greet oh I bet that you be
fine
without
[Music]
it every little thing that you got to
have every little thing that you got to
have you got to reach for and you got to
grab oh I bet that you be fine without
it so take your eyes
we or take your
[Music]
eyes
away